in the last half hour u.s secretary of
state mike pompeo has declared al-qaeda
has established a new home base
in iran he made that assertion without
any hard evidence
in what appears to be a last-minute
offensive against tehran as pompeo and
the rest of the trump administration
prepare to leave power in washington
he also said he could confirm the death
of al-qaeda's abu mohammed al-masri
that death was reported last year a
master gunned down by israeli operatives
in al qaeda
has a new home base it is the islamic
republic
of iran as a result
bin laden's wicked creation is poised to
gain strength
and capabilities we ignore this
iran al-qaeda nexus at our own peril
we need to acknowledge it we must
confront it indeed we must
defeat it so let's start with alan
fisher
at the white house allen we were talking
last hour about things that
usually happened in the last week of an
administration
uh how does this sort of sit in that
usual
time frame
it's certainly not unheard of but it is
rather
unusual that the secretary of state
would make such a speech and that he
would
declassify information during a speech
drawing links between al qaeda and iran
just by contrast the these rumors these
stories
these allegations have been around for
some considerable time over a number of
years
even before 9 11 there was talk of iran
having connections with al qaeda
certainly the intelligence community has
always been very skeptical of that
idea mike pompeo has always been keen to
demonize
iran he's very much behind donald
trump's idea of maximum pressure he is
of course
a former cia director so he will get
intelligence across
his desk that some in the intelligence
community won't even see
but we know that the the center for
strategic and international studies very
important think tank here in the united
states
at the end of 2019 published a report
that suggested
the links between al qaeda and iraq iran
are very very small indeed and suggested
that if there were
high-profile members of al qaeda there
was maybe no more than
five living in iran that really doesn't
matter to mike pompeo of course he will
suggest that if you've got one you've
got more than enough
there's a concern that mike pompeo is
doing two things first of all making it
very difficult for the biden
administration the incoming biden
administration
to make any sort of peace moves towards
iran
for any sort of approach to to make sure
that the two nations get on better
and perhaps even consider going back
into the iran nuclear deal which was
negotiated
by joe biden's old boss barack obama's
administration
the second thing that some people on the
hill are very concerned about
is that by tying al qaeda to iran then
mike pompeo and donald trump and the
administration would then have an excuse
to launch some sort of attack
in iran itself now to go and do that
sort of thing you would normally need
congressional approval
given that the house is controlled by
democrats given that the senate is now
controlled by democrats you're not going
to get that however
there is an ongoing authorization for
the use of military force
which targets al-qaeda so if you could
go and say
well we weren't attacking iran we were
attacking members of al qaeda
that is why we carried out that attack
that would certainly give them that and
we know
that there's been some concern
particularly since the turn of the year
that donald trump might be planning some
sort of assault on iran
there's nothing really concrete to back
that up just
some grumbling some chatter in the
intelligence community
annoying fear for some but uh
that would certainly be a a way to
explain
any action that they take if they say
well there is
this authorization for the use of
military force against al-qaeda that is
why we launched that assault not saying
that anything like that is going to
happen
but that is in a way trying to put
that pompeo speech in some sort of
context and so why say all of this now
as we point out so close to the end of
the
administration is this i mean one of the
reasons maybe another attempt to pull
some focus away from everything else
that's going on
well two reasons for it one uh he's not
got the platform to do this much
more often and as i say he's trying to
make things difficult for the incoming
biden administration to make any sort of
moves towards
iran which has been really a country
that has
been targeted by the trump
administration from the very early days
remember back in 2016 before the
election then
donald trump said that one of the first
things he would do on day one would
pull out of the iran nuclear deal he was
talked out of that in a couple of
occasions when he had to
reauthorize but when it came to doing it
for the third time he said i'm
absolutely not doing it
and and refused to do it so pulled the
plug on it at that point
the other thing is mike pompeo is
interested in running for the
presidential nomination for the
republican party in 2024
so being tough in iran he believes plays
well to the base and makes him look
strong
and certainly if you continue to attack
iran
it plays well with conservative base
america has scar tissue from what
happened
during the carter administration when
the hostages were taken
at the iranian embassy they do not trust
iran
that has been the case for many many
many years donald trump to a degree
tapped into that rather than played up
on it he tapped into that and so
there is always a concern about what
iran is going to do next
and in some cases people close to donald
trump would say they've been justified
in in some of the things that iran has
done and they've been it's been true
with
with what they've predicted and what
they've said but they would like to
continue
this campaign of maximum pressure
and they're hoping that by highlighting
this it makes it much more difficult for
joe biden to step away from that
alan fisher's at the white house thank
you for that alan
uh reaction from iran with our
correspondent in the moment i just want
to show you this tweet first of all
javid zarif
we'll go into this in more detail with
dawson jabar in a moment but you know
lines there about warmongering lies
no one has fooled all 911 terrorists
came from secretary pompeo's favorite
middle east destinations none from iran
that's the
iranian foreign minister dulce jabari i
mean
predictable sort of reaction from the
iranians
there but mike pompeo came out with a
lot of
well he came out with a lot of specifics
without necessarily
backing it up with evidence
yes certainly he said that he had
documentation that provided uh
proof that the nine eight of the 9 11
hijackers had traveled to
or through iran prior to the attack that
was carried out on september 11
in 2001 but he didn't specify
what purpose they had for traveling
through this country
he also said that very she believed very
strongly that they have set up al qaeda
has set up an office
base in iran and that they are
continuing their fundraising activities
and he put forth some very very
um distinct and very strong
possibilities or scenarios that if
there was a strong relationship between
this government or the system in iran
and al-qaeda
the combination could be very very uh
deadly for the international community
that they should not let that happen
this kind of language this kind of
rhetoric that was used by
mike pompeo reminded me of when
colin powell was speaking at the u.n in
2003
before the united states invaded iraq it
seemed like there was a groundwork of
being laid
for an excuse to carry out some kind of
an action
this is of course something that we've
heard uh like alan mentioned there was
there's been rumors of this whispers of
this over the past few months that
president trump
wanted to strike some of iran's nuclear
facilities in order to deter
the country from pursuing any further
its nuclear activities but
iran for its part has been very very uh
strong in their position they haven't uh
altered at
all we heard from the supreme leader on
friday who said that
the iranians aren't waiting for the u.s
to return to the jcpoa or the nuclear
agreement of 2015.
what they want is an immediate lifting
of the sanctions that the
u.s has imposed on iran since they
withdrew from the deal in 2018.
they've left it that's fine and we don't
care what is the feeling
but the sanctions they've imposed on us
since then
are absolutely inhumane and have had
really
serious economic consequences on the
population of this country
so that is the position here and this
speech
will be seen as another attempt by this
administration in the final days
to try and uh make things very very
difficult for
president-elect joe biden who of course
has had a personal relationship
of about 30 years with foreign minister
mohammad javad zarif
the foreign minister was the iranian
ambassador to the un
uh decades ago at the same time joe
biden
was also working for the us
within the un so the two have had
numerous meetings they have
had some kind of a relationship in the
past and the foreign minister javad
zarif has spoken about that relationship
and he said that
he believes the president elect to be
much more uh
logical and much more well versed in
foreign policy and
understanding this region so there is a
sense that the incoming administration
will see things very very differently
and certainly this language that we
heard
uh today will not be heard in the coming
weeks after
january 20th thank you dolce jabari in
tehran